les esprits égarés sont en effet souvent
confus et parfois en colère ouais ça a
été un plaisir de travailler avec toi j'aurais seulement
aimé t'avoir sur mon prochain projet
merci j'aimerais bien mais nous partons
demain pour un concert et je connais une
équipe de télévision à embaucher êtes-vous prêt
pour certains fantômes, vous ne pensez pas que ça
va être effrayant le cerf a un nouveau travail et
l'Idaho éloigné pas de service de téléphone portable pas de
Twitter pas de Facebook enquêtant sur une
activité paranormale avez-vous déjà vu
quelque chose ici l'emplacement ici est une
maison de ranch qui a été désertée depuis
plus  30 ans,
c'est tellement cool que ma mère tuerait pour
ce poêle antique,
elle a dit qu'elle avait l'impression que deux mains la
poussaient mais qu'elle était autrefois en sommeil
avant d'appeler les flics mais pourquoi voudriez-
vous le supprimer toute la vie Je
voulais juste être riche cupide divise l'
équipage et transforme ces chasseurs de haute technologie
en
chassés c'est tout pour une certaine réalité  montrer pour
survivre qu'ils auront besoin de l'aide d'au-delà des
chasseurs d'esprits que
vous